[Applause]
three of the top producers at the ellen
degeneres show are
out amid a workplace misconduct
investigation at the daytime talk show
a spokesperson for warner brothers
confirms to et
that executive producers ed glavin and
kevin lehmann
and co-executive producer jonathan
norman have parted ways with the program
e.t has also learned that derrick
westervelt mary connolly
and andy lassner will remain at the show
as executive producers
alongside ellen house dj steven twitch
boss has
also been named co-executive producer in
recent months
her character has been called into
question what do you say to those
critics
i have personally seen all the love that
she puts in
in the world so it's just like people
just people just got time
you know people got time so i mean we'll
always try to tear people that are on
top down
yeah e.t has learned that news of the
shake-up was delivered to the staff
on monday during a zoom meeting where
the 62-year-old talk show host
apologized to anyone whose feelings were
hurt
i you know i think that i was a nice
person to begin with and i hope i've
gotten nicer
ellen also acknowledged that mistakes
were made before noting how grateful she
is for her team
i stay grateful and i try to stay humble
and i think that i
pay attention to what is important and
what is real and in addition to all of
that
e.t has learned that hr changes were
also announced to help improve the work
environment
and the employee experience at the show
of course this whole thing started back
in july after buzzfeed
news published an article which included
anonymous accounts of misconduct at the
show
from a dozen former and one current
employee
glavin lehmann and norman were all cited
in the article and were reportedly
suspended
at the time warner brothers television
sent an internal memo to staff
informing them that an independent
third-party firm would be hired to
interview
current and former employees about their
experiences behind the scenes
and in an internal letter sent to the
show's staff obtained by et
ellen apologized and said she was
committed to having conversations about
fairness and justice i don't think you
achieve anything by
by bullying people e.t has also learned
that the workplace investigation
is still ongoing and a source close to
the team
says that ellen's main priority right
now is the staff
i started out as a comedian and i wanted
to make people laugh and i wanted to
make people happy and feel good